it was not
thanks for your patience that will ignite
real country why not pino good morning
welcome everyone thanks
for coming for this
press conference with the commissioner as
his last mission in italy as commissioner
the word between commissioner good morning
everyone thanks for coming if  tones
that median acquired the commissioner
[Music]
giuseppe conte made the family from
bossi pastures jentzsch on pos criteria and
times and soft cell european lines again
essential good to consider the poles
tyrants should be commission
giuseppe turrisi perhaps the hobbit italy
you used them  for the piagge travaglia and
therefore oba everything is possible
arik shivek the cuts of tenna young
but from my opinion little heard
good morning everyone I am therefore I am here
for my last trip as a
saleswoman as a commissioner and
precisely wanted this last one of mine to
move  was precisely in italy for
two reasons firstly because i love italy
then because i think ita  lia is an
absolutely essential country for
the European Union as well as the
European Union and without a king for Italy in the
five years during which I have been
Commissioner I can say that I have
truly made every effort to bring Italy closer to
the
European Union and vice versa and  this with all the
governments that have followed in your
country
here we like our sea basket tired
of desiati and companions and the whole
world does Italian journalists that the
skies of right that there are on the real and
here
the Romanist d and then the  another reason that I
have been during these five years
in all my travels always
accompanied by Italian journalists
for which the thing that will happen from it
in short is that it will really make you
realize in short that no longer this one in
charge as well as too many
Italian journalists and therefore appeal  to those who grow up
little in via questo yesterday if you end up in
bad luck fra legato always mission notes my
way my ami paolo gentiloni famous king's case i
don't bring his magn  factories with
what a body can do than consumption and
therefore precisely when I no
longer see young Italians it will mean that the
next stage is really the
boxes for the office and I am very
happy and of course my successor
is paolo gentiloni gossett visit
feeble taken  and that the notes crociglia his
clinton laughs it click sergio mattarella
and we're sorry that positive to old
taken with him giuseppe conte leclé
ministers who I call myself blessed
gualtieri had to be confirmed and
soon also the president of the confindustria had something to do with yesterday tv in the opposite direction
therefore
so in my life in italy i
had the pleasure of
being received by the president of the
republic
and of having also had discussions a
very positive dialogue this morning
with the president of the council with you and
with the minister of the economy roberto
gualtieri my next stop after
this conference will be an interview with
vincenzo boccia president  of
confindustria on cofidi a co computer
then the who let's start putting
economic and fiscal discussions in a
bang it's just argumentative enemies for the
group I said but with whom the area or gold
libo community comfortable milk on
mouthfuls on the blog in the water sounds on 7
in  here are consecutive skating chanel
and mouthfuls on the planisphere mar his quarrel
to today the sun can made a new
behind them 7 from that santoso therefore
I think it is precisely the case seen at the
end of my mandate to make a sort
of balance of course for what
it concerns the economic and fiscal aspects
that have made up my portfolio
so let's start with the economic sphere
where we can truly say mission
accomplished with regard to the eurozone
compared to November 2014
we actually had practically seven
consecutive years of growth and that is
obviously something  it is also remarkable with
regard to unemployment, which
went from 11.5 per cent to 7.5 per
cent  yes musical up to more bricks
first things responsibility
canon web and a little zero deficit exif
euro bionaz goose we thirsty and melts
the iv and of the crisis the bike votu me
poison votes after the crisis or does many
parts like langres up to all  along the exit
push the body catas lanting the area
and the commission from 17 to breath the good
cuteri list but it is her that a continent
of him the fat see fea
we do not have a cockpit travail confirmation
in the crimes
and therefore regarding  the
public finances of most of the
member states were weakened precisely in 2014
many countries were in
excessive deficit procedure and today
no one in any eurozone country
is in this situation however in
2014 investments also collapsed
below the  effect of the crisis
while today we are well above
pre-crisis levels and even
the integrity of the eurozone was threatened
by the possible grex itlug raxit that
we have practically  nt touched and I am
very happy to be able to say that
we found ourselves on the
right side of history and that Greece has
been averted and that even if the Greek one does, it
must make further efforts, the Greek government must make
further efforts, however we are
in fact in  a situation today absolutely
sustainable the commissions divide mobile
responsible 7 best shares media
contributed the maca politicians a volonté
politics between pub set commission and an
amen
those who criticize it flexibility from the
applications pay established iphone
structural puleo great and social
we had it on the bike it will extend and
five missions  the beat the
critique
therefore goes precisely with regard to
these these positive results it
cannot be said that it is solely the merit of the
commission but certainly the
commission contributed amply
because there was truly a
political brand imprinted on this action a
political will precisely to  contribute  re
to these good results in this sense
and this precisely through
this triptych which has been constituted
we have put in place which has been
constituted precisely by flexibility gives
structural responses which are that have
been given to the economic situation and
support for investments with the plan
junker we came to italy because i
leave you threads of such but a cube that
defined them for him that it happened in port
of the jet set formulas
in the texts beaucoup to 32 gb park the
snack pass confirms it
you can adapt the web is more blick who
thinks that  if chronic de micheli from there is
who has a little tonsils the name and then of
course I would like to talk about
Italy in Italy which I have dealt with
very and very intensely during
these five years we know that the
economic and social challenges in your country
are important
that there is still a lot to do there is a lot
to do to revive growth and to
bring down the public debt that weighs heavily on
this great economy that h  a however such
an important potential
9 that the world and lakes taken by os
that beck italian government
damon greg hard determined to
do it of tool ligurian italian that
all division saturday online easy volley
the crisis me but i pg tel
all for me toni  and books on old tones
economic crisis with few
governments I have to say precisely how
my dialogue with Italy has been so
intense here maybe it's right with the with
with greece and I'm talking leave this
I'm talking about all the governments that have
followed one another  in these five years
it hasn't been easy for all the managers of all the managements
we have even in some
moments touched a
real crisis but if we have we have
always managed to find
satisfactory solutions to maintain a
seriousness precisely at the level of the budget
supporting in the same  time the
economic recovery justice se ducation situ of
optical satellites present with six
outfits finozzi polo collaboration siliani
athens growth p  hosts the assaults list
don omar in nemi dle italy
the most sic how to say in daniel a world
if there is a fresh italy my door was
open and therefore I want to take this
opportunity to really thank
all my interlocutors precisely in the
various governments that  have followed one
another due to their collaboration in recent
years I am speaking of both the various minis, in short, the
ministers of finance and the economy
of the presidents of the council
I really believe that especially
especially in that period of crisis
that I mentioned earlier also the Italians
also the people  Italian has
realized that I am truly a friend of
Italy and that both the
Italians and their governments have always
found as I found myself saying
last year that as the Commissioner said
in Italian my door
was open that  muslims in tusk paolo
gentiloni of the posts did it 4
may all owe you is ready now
well-known echo enemies what a new hole that
faces slash club c  ooking fires
answers him watches that there are not many
delays pay with vitality like the thing
in the world gt2 brivio lotto and public
paul via us with
reduced emi father piccoli piva the two policemen
0 shop bridget is at risk of contagion
sadly passons apple a4 between june the
bus and forecast together with a select few
nor life
therefore I think that to speak briefly about
the future and I say briefly because of
course then my successor Paolo Gentiloni will take care of it I
see however for the future of the
economic challenges as regards precisely the
next commission is the first of
these  The challenge is certainly that of the
economic slowdown that we are observing in this
period I believe that we can
act precisely at this level aa3
precisely levels in the sense that there are
countries such as Italy, France, for example,
others that have to reduce their
debt Italy a little  more than france
and then there are countries like germany and
the netherlands which can play
more on l  gold leeway
to better support
investments two fixed centers i say
perhaps ascites closes the democratic zone more
fixed it passes to class 1 feb
of its new carelessness our moka
tics of the zone and speaks or maybe world
wood matteo a sette  races are the
questions if there is the tropez mechanism reform
at the basic end to the
brand new born problem that sticks here yes
but there is another challenge therefore his
challenge is to reinforce
the architecture of the eurozone for
make it more democratic and
give it more power I'm thinking precisely of the
union with the banking union
because we have we don't
yet have a real budget
budget for the euro area I am also thinking
of democratic governance and I am thinking
precisely of the union  banking and the
reform of the European
Stability Mechanism which is not a
problem but constitutes progress or
fantasies difficult to worlds of hg widget
we do not use facebook cupola flexibilit  y
the post but all his sadism quality
the stability pact the step on the fly
with fixable puglisi b but overall
and he can however under the contributed to
bring in the fast on site if you are in
detail and paolo gentiloni
then we have the third challenge  the
budgetary rules and as far as the
budgetary rules are concerned, I am sure that
we have used all that we
could have used with respect to the pact and
I believe that there is a need, which is to
make sure that this pact can truly be
able to remit  point is
a review let's say to become
simpler to become more readable
and to constitute a real pro
relationship to growth moved our
26 the vote and spotlights who want to whistle it
podiums took about these
commissions and rai you are potatoes direct in
all in and limit to the cocktail dogs
manga technician nasa ne ecuador neural
world leader macchiato league with that
photo and tax evasion and og  ni such
scholarship holders of android
sieves new christian lends on dvd
we notice that there too it comes strong but
not located discretion show the house on the
web box
a san lucid passed the new
provassimo then we have precisely the
second ambit of what was ok
that is  was my portfolio problem,
i.e. the fiscal one and here too I must
say that we have done a lot in the fight
against tax evasion and tax fraud
has certainly experienced
a new momentum
we have adopted 20 directives and we have
done more I must say precisely  in five
years of what had been done in
the last twenty years therefore
something absolutely crucial for Europe
also such as for example the web tax and
everything could also be done
within the OECD on its contribution
discussion on the 5 9 holes  stu
now here are the elements that
I wanted to provide you with regards
precisely a balance sheet of what
was mine our work and now I
am awaiting  your questions
let's go with my colleague
until we look at it capodacqua chance of some
logan domenico conti four handle
juan mendez is monitored give its own
digital jobs plant in audience in which
way of sms night only right vito
slow but with those nuclei at the age of
budget position of
neighboring agro-foods fail data the
rhythm of faith next year post for in
spring a modo
[Music]
maybe garrison ode seen own site
little sophie situation also parma
seduces us from the funds the meeting goes well
established and the italian office  a
pleasure your credit 59 giuseppe conte
di adecco berthod golfieri of course
the european stability mechanism and the
italian budget were at the heart
of the discussions and that i was able to have a
conversation that i was able to have that
weight gualtieri group more than ba
italian politician i don't want  interfere with the
italian political debate
the old panthers of politics and
have known them of atlus i  the fund the
mechanisms copy it established
commission usa you say otherwise deville
that you see indomitable
that even if translated the arrivals of
mechanisms 8 morning build on the
other hand so called the mechanism
by copying established sites chosen
by ge tel solutions
yes if the 72 more automatic then if
between funds pai type
the commission kisses the puc on the
broom lka now every post
then for that in the meantime as
regards the European
stability mechanism I want to answer you
that in the meantime we have
avoided drifts in this regard which
could have been absolutely
harmful which instead  other countries would have
liked to introduce
automatisms which we
decided not to implement because
precisely in that month it could have
replaced
the auto mode mechanisms but also for
us the commission really fought
to make sure that it was not  so the
two census would come out entrance of ge  orges
world the three canvases moved
the application know thin that you
click on sky.it will tell the will of the
best santiago each appropriate decided
one with the father innovation or smoke if
therefore continuity and then the second
thing for example which is very
overrated
the
changes in changes to these changes to the
treaty are greatly overestimated.
there
won't be a big one let's say there won't be a
profound change no profound
appointment in this regard is on
youtube are you fans the codacons italy a
good one who according to monastic slow food
nation who also many to come from the
hypothesis or in vogue the bank has taken
away  three tafers of the fire and the woods or gas
and protection mo 2 s.diego with cable or di bach
did not move nepa political problems and
tom settennat  or politelli and a package
consists in the mouth here then I also want to
say that precisely as I was saying
this is a step forward
also for example towards the
banking union that backstop to which
we care a lot
for the resolution fund for which
precisely that  he saw us as helpful if
a bank or some banks were to
have problems it is easy
to fail so I don't understand precisely
why Italy should consider
this a problem in our opinion it is
rather a help and progress for the
Italian banking system only the
project  who goes p bonus with plan
whoever asks me comes but what is behind the
lies italy and sushi where you wait true
they use plans he asked him at risk
non-compliant you if type of accusing a
dot true the dialogue has decreed the
three italians
for how much  then it concerns the
Italian budget the dialogue with the Italian authorities will continue
the good job was done
we worked well together
we exchanged  iati letters and emails is a
balance sheet that precisely goes in the sense
of respecting the
parameters even if there is a risk of non-
compliance for which
the dialogue with the Italian authorities will continue,
so you fish tonight or pato you are  it
happened to me like this it was dialogue with dsa
promoted with fiom
the italian government region panevin
giuseppe conte mentioned gualtieri etf
council of the association yes it was strong
it was close to the best i think with 79
bridge and home i with which the arch of the
fiscal reasons that  a
tel aviv and non kb software can do everything with the
complex so I can't naturally
anticipate what will be decided I said
in the spring but I must say that I am very
confident
in this period I have had
talks with both the president and the
minister some who  are truly
aware of the efforts that are
needed to ensure more outdated
alitalia to continue the fight against
tax fraud and eva  fiscal sion and
therefore we absolutely
agreed on these points
roberto bozzi where the suppressed sky news
was from the cloud rise of riddick use
youtube discretion 3 positive technicians
conte instead gualtieri received thought
you know it succeeds or the effect is italy
the fa also had the cell version of the
razon
eclipse it's god sic jade screw avec italia
recco between laughs and it's tense apple mirror
problems you have time so me
iacono méndez I'll wait two sets john key or
a direkt pro way it's doors to
restructuring has it  said naked does not
designate stake sic risks
if whoever proposed it is known old risk
on publique ideas years vote and committee
and balsio the bon season cures in
such a short way clip international bank it
happened if you put in too ipa crean disa
competitive advantage the
european system mercy  after
giuseppe conte recalled districts so
pal constructive discretion
we are at the exits of
the palms or nonsense the manie can stop  ra o
and he system in Italian politics
famous opposition knows he expects it on the
basis of his in the rope the capitals
in the places the Easter boxe position
ghost of the objective manor the norms
the brides of christ in nepal normal
deformed the réalité knows he goes away  the other
probes of the policies and I could do it more
that is count neighborhood workers this world does
not prepare for sony such for prints the
details and dad olmetto league the
divine groove there yes it will give soft the
good they broke out
and therefore as I said I spoke to the
president of the council with you with the
mixed some that we have
indeed exchanged ours our
ideas it always concerns a
European stability mechanism we have indeed found that we
have
several convergences between us now however it
is not up to me of course to replace myself or
speak on behalf of the  Italian government of
Italian politicians because then when
everything obviously falls within the
sovereignty of the Italian state
whatever you want  or to say I is that
this topic should be tackled
without details without details
without taboos let's say it is obviously not normal
to ask oneself normal questions to
try to investigate what is
not good instead it is to distort reality
one has to put back with a French way of saying
that he used  the inspector the
church in the center of the village
and then added obviously it's strange
said in rome in short it was already said
and therefore in short above all use
common sense managed to giusy a
limited number the computer fair milocco on the bit
disgusting
there is a  bit of bones the craftsmen
evoke the pit and the mechanisms
who puts it aside the stability of local
that the consuls and exhausted of the models
of the kits by matt elderly the pay world of
sm
and ne ne sapessi writes the site
fluid composers silvio c donk  infopath vita
disse put the post
that closed or suspicious them into a situation toulon suez
richest italian flowers visit to
sapremo baschi lec  co beasts and if the tera
of italy in its network of on
the info that the conduit
tel italy is almost 5000 junior st gobbi and
donkey it was who you are aware of them or in
maine that with breath disasters kition
own reality was born i was
saying  precisely it is
a matter of common sense in particular there
are things that are already in the
European stability mechanism already exist precisely there
are already stability mechanisms
with regard to debt they are already
present yes it is allowed yes it is
facilitated as  say this was already there before
too the dialogue with private investors
let's say that these elements
are somehow damaged more fluidly there is
a purification of these elements now
all of this is in favor of reducing Italy
's debt as
regards  of your country and it is
obviously in Italy's interest to
reduce the debt for which I do not
find that there should be room for
doubts on the fact that Italy has been
accused of something that is
known  something nobody wanted to
put italy under
guardianship italy is a big country and a dominant
member of the european union it must
have self-confidence and trust
in international institutions
tourist buses mapelli dai i loved
networks 4 i wanted to ask you in italian
if your mandate ends soon
you will have 10 thousand euros in this time
to do nothing for Europe from
now on this European decision seems correct to you
and then another
limited pardons for the
reintegration allowance as all the
commissioners have  in Europe it's not over 10
thousand euros so I wanted to know if at
the moment it seems right to me to take
this money even if you won't continue
to work that Europe the other
question what to do with them and they ask
from maicon these the other question
always concerns  this is the situation
in which the outgoing commissioners can
still take this money
from Europe to continue working
even for private groups  you are not commissioner
and so let's say collect even more
money, this disappointment also seems correct to you
a decision that as
commissioner and therefore groups that you as
commissioner should have checked
another question would be do you think the
salary as commissioner is in
question and you have received hold that it
salary as commissioner who receives if
you want two commissioners he has
adequate especially in view of the
results
let's say it's not all
visible enough to everyone of what you
have in europe the last question concerns
the pension is more like commissioners you
will earn 4 thousand euros a month
working five  years in europe of
european citizens
we have the world pensions championship and the
saint is a boy who beware
because they are countries that i reply to the
emails that arrive from all the
transmissions of the question point straight
to everything concerning and with the
times the european council a  respond with
the tablet to crash the last
visit unitaly  community of poe palezza
me2 has moved ve thirst for cash also an
effect with 6 that exist closed and
on the occasion who supports the fittest
no the coni commissaire voting center
and directors pier aspects of radio results there
are those on a couple ex camon  against the pale
committees of deontology a sanna
commission exposed escape serene as
you will find a little you put yourself the overall man
or sit diabolical whether you quote
patton deprived with dogs book or whose side
the dog module must be the world
therefore I will be brief  as far as
this is concerned, the questions you
asked this answer of mine is
obviously not the main
reason why I came to Italy and I
'm not here precisely to answer
this kind of question, but I still want to
answer them to tell you that  this
lease this check serves precisely
to avoid and for those who set it up to
avoid that, for example, a
commissioner of commissioners could
yield to some attempts  actions at the end
of their mandate which is like saying precisely
facilitating compliance with certain
ethical rules, however there is a form of
control which is exercised precisely to be
given by specific deontological committees
therefore jesus the commission for
space to the relationship in which which places the
young people on my cooling of who in front of
the dante harmony but I fear not pive
solutions the file contribution and you know with
housekeepers or political theses
there is even if it weren't so
important if it weren't precisely
the last part of the answer he has
previously given by the commissioner who
had also said precisely that if there
were no measures of this type it could also
be that perhaps someone
could give in to some temptation and
go into the private sector and earn
really very large sums by
selling their own contacts
added here precisely that c  'it is a
real procedure called culina
off which is precisely used
precisely to prevent a commissioners  or
precisely that it is no longer that that function no longer performs
precisely it
rushes into the private sector with results and whoever we
say doubts about some
commission sheets tyutin all wounded
I also think forgive me forgive me
forgive me and I also think finally that it is
important that the  the Italians
know well that the work of the
commission is useful and not only useful,
I would say it is really important,
sorry, collected by email sent but
you did an afternoon of work and,
moreover, I specified that all the
republican attacks on everyone that I
replied to all  the questions
I know this he answered with him never
where I sent to the affect and we don't
owe anything more than this he doesn't
do it in writing that we answered
all saints are more I ask maybe a
question that approaches a little more
monetary life is a  word that in short
of the Italians of the year
I also want to know another thing and
you started
to speak aloud
but
no guard loudly let's hope and
Francesca Sforza to the press instead
acknowledge that we say in the station
to cut off all social
[Music]
when asked about lilac and Italy
right so I heard the state it was
the press says gianni papa
official launch giuseppe conte you don't want it
because remembered  districts
the gloomy if the Italian government from aspi
and acumen its missions plans saw moves
undergoes one are positive clean the
eboli travaglio the Italian I wrote it
have been a finger it was of little use
I did not speak about this topic with
the prime minister bridge  Instead, I
spoke about it with the messenger. It's
the only thing I can say that the
Italian government is really really
doing everything to find
solutions in view of solutions
that are positive for Italy and
above all positive for Italian workers
given that  that's what it's
about in the first place
[Music]
plus this bossi
i reckon
not yes
the man
yes
if possible if even wait  I'm not
only
here
sorry all the questions on
Italian politics sorry if we want
finally for life to say the
president of the council has
asked for life
if they are possible to live yes here
we say for his colleagues because
I don't feel very well from here  you know very
dry why giuseppe conte
roberto where the teletext thriller successes
and which we accept
in concrete terms yes it goes without saying that the
son is 7 with closed agreements
the signs of a national quota have been contested
no i
did not speak i did not speak about this the  the only
thing I feel like saying is that a
text that was already accepted
in June also by the former
government of the previous government
magath there were
people together with the previous government
who today are talking about it in a way
completely different, however, they were there
too, on the other hand, they
are international agreements with the
dignity of international agreements
bonjour m  arilena vinci tonight italy
green think that this governance and
small ball and preview sua ma about the
turning point of salvini dublin when
china said that you're in
eurobowl  the sole purpose of 5 kg dry
and here you are spontaneous but then I used
to turn off the purposes n that you
talk here easy like paul rust
mousavi or siro and it is known bucella in my
region for counts and young people before
the unknown almost epics  Italian people
I think maybe this time ct super his
ideological as
long as they are slaves the ball tour but
because they drove that the kilo in the
meantime I always speak with
all the governments of whatever mold they
are I am careful not to judge the
governments of other countries whose thing
I can  to say with respect to the
differences between today's government and the
previous one is that the current one
seems to me more spontaneously oriented
towards respect for the rules and in
this  this sense the dialogue is easier
but also worked very well with the
previous government precisely working with
the president conte and with the minister
tria i have to say that in fact he is minister
both he proved to be a
courageous and effective politician
apologize more than  your name on savini you
pass ucai cures we will not feel
on a political course skate if the
new ones with crisis give instead 9 suites use
canizzaro policies that kiswa fini
spa with me for plastic vitals and dona
are and there is even if position  mania for
fat bass so since even that
non-egg part enters the fox
politelli fashions the trays and 12 on Saturday but
which
alcoas the peppery collision which directs
use immediately as regards what
he called the Salvini breakthrough I think
it will not  let it be a mystery to no one that
salvini and I have not always
gotten along I would even say that it is the least
that can be said that we have not
always gotten along well so my I have to
say I am  a veto in a very
favorable way as always happens to me the
fact that in any case a leader of a
European country realizes the importance
of remaining in
the eurozone I personally am truly
convinced that the euro that belonging to the
eurozone is  a really
strong element for italy I'm
absolutely sure
the artists maybe the last question will
go to pila milano finance I
'd go back to the question from the
stability mechanism
I wanted to understand there's the risk that it turns
out to be ineffective in some way because
given the conditions that are opposite can
leave out the countries that have more
need to access credit lines
and the other question concerns the
lenders the backstop
the anticipation of the backstop has been
linked to the reduction of performing
loans leaving bent excuse me  all to the
reduction of non-performing loans
as the banks leave out
other assets in liquids which can
create risks for the  banks of some
countries
you see this problem and therefore nothing
in front of the 9 place of donated only
réponse office and legitimate software the
site yesterday Italian Italian politics
are susceptible to posey a teacher
you are also
the kit athletes schulman aseptic set
maker technician we were the series mo  who I
am I would recommend show thumbs taken
negative that you can or others the
experience politics and peace who knew
bagged growing up the stripes open gt
paintings we occupy today in his
cottage may you and yours accompany
me as well when the data instead post
settete italcon comino  o accept in favor of
Italy
then I do not want and I absolutely do not feel
like adding anything else to
the essential questions
in which I am aware that they
can arise
both from the Italian people and from
Italian politicians therefore I will not add anything else  in
reality of technician of the answers that I have
already given and that in fact respond to
those that are there  and essential questions
what I can tell you to
complete my answer is that here we are
talking about a treatise that is rather
technical being technical and complex it
will necessarily have points that
can seem more positive and
points that can seem more negative
for one  or for the other country,
however, I began to have a
fairly extensive experience at the political level since
I've been in the
European institutions for 25 years, I started in '94
and the other thing I would tell you that I would
feel like saying to everyone is that a
treaty by definition is a
compromise it is not the point of view of
one or the other country
in the context of this definition of a
treaty as a compromise precisely the
different interests my
real belief is that this treaty is really
favorable
not even neutral but favorable
to the  live italy every day the highlight
is also discovering mister geretto the
italian journalists gesture function is
more blick to receive opportunities after finished
there
and who if the two mix primiano www.al
james cotton it is here that he put no one of
passions tv kippah here now
i leave you as i said at the beginning of
my
speech i don't know how many occasions i have
before he said precisely because
commissioner who will I allocate other
opportunities to see Italian journalists around me
in reality but yes because
I intend to continue to remain
in the public debate and
therefore we will perhaps still have the opportunity to
meet since I really love Europe
I really love Italy and these are
passions  that last regardless of
whether you are a commissioner or not yes thank you
[Music]